first pipes don't respect pandemics so
don is dealing with an urgent call from
a client
thanks to coronavirus all that emergency
work has dried up leaving the
self-employed plumber facing uncertain
times I'm really trying to do my best to
stay away from people as much as
possible
follow the advice but yeah at the same
time you've got that constant pressure
that I'm not earning money you know all
my bills still got to be paid
essentially so yeah there is a
definitely a pressure there to go and
work Chancellory she soon ak has
promised measures to support millions of
self-employed workers that told
Parliament they will have to wait a
little longer for the details we
absolutely understand the situation that
many self-employed people face at the
moment as a result of what's happening
and are determined to find a way to
support them we just need to be we need
to be confident that can be done in a
way that is deliverable and is fair to
the vast majority of the British
workforce
[Music]
construction accounts for the largest
group among the self-employed and the
government says building sites can
continue as long as people maintain a
safe distance which may keep some
earning for now helping the
self-employed is complicated one of the
challenges for the Treasury is that the
self-assessment tax system which can
cover any one from barristers to
builders
doesn't provide an accurate guide to
who's in need of support how much they
might deserve or of getting money for
those in need until they find a solution
those running sites like James in
Bristol face a dilemma between keeping
staff safe and keeping them earning as
the government's not being clear the
drip-feeding information they should
make a firm decision for to help
self-employed people because we've got
plenty of self-employed contractors who
are now stuck financially in complete
despair and they need some sort of
reassurance from the government Charlie
had Jack usually sing for their supper
with pubs and clubs closed and all
celebrations on hold bookings have
evaporated there's no work at all so it
couldn't have had a greater impact
really the wedding business you know run
a wedding band with Jack and we are
facing sort of you know the next three
months minimum of no work whatsoever
[Music]
the government says loans and universal
credit are available to the
self-employed but until their support
matches employees there will be discord
Paul Kelso Sky News in Bristol